die sommerferien neigen sich jetzt dem
ende kommende woche fängt das schuljahr
in mecklenburg vorpommern wieder an und
kurz danach dann auch in weiteren
bundesländern bildungsministerin anja
karliczek spricht jetzt über szenarien
wie der schulbeginn während der pandemie
dann laufen kann aber nicht alle sehen
das so unproblematisch
anfang august geht in den ersten
bundesländern der schulbetrieb wieder
los doch haben die länder die
hausaufgaben hinsichtlich corona gemacht
für bundesbildungsministerin anja
karliczek ist klar der idealfall wäre
der regelbetrieb in der schule
doch die kultusminister der länder
richten sich auf drei varianten ein das
eine ist eben regelbetrieb mit hygiene
konzept das zweite ist ein hybrides
schulmodell wo ein teil der kinder vor
ort unterrichtet wird im
präsenzunterricht andere eben digital
und die dritte variante ist die wenn das
infektionsgeschehen hoch ist wenn wir da
irgendwo ein ausbruch ist das mal
vielleicht auch kurzzeitig noch mal zum
homeschooling zurückkehren kann
das erneute mögliche homeschooling setzt
allerdings voraus dass auch finanziell
schwächer gestellte schüler
entsprechende hardware zur verfügung
gestellt bekommen und wir haben gerade
in den letzten monaten viele
unterstützung auch von bundesseite
gegeben das eine ist das jetzt
flächendeckend aus den schulen heraus
kinder mit endgeräten ausgestattet
werden können wenn sie von zu hause
keine endgeräte haben also unterstützung
für bedürftige das zweite ist dass wir
auch noch mal aus dem digital packt
heraus beschleunigungs möglichkeiten
gegeben haben dass man vorab jetzt schon
in schulen zum beispiel wlan
organisieren und einrichten kann
auch wenn man das konzept noch nicht
abgeliefert hat dass man eben die
technischen details hat aber die
umsetzung muss vor ort in den ländern
passieren aber wie gut sie die schulen
darauf vorbereitet die vorstellungen der
bildungsministerin umzusetzen
heinz peter meidinger der präsident des
deutschen lehrerverbandes meldet zweifel
an kali checks konzepten an ob
tatsächlich die bedingungen so sind dass
man auf das abstandsgebot verzichten
kann
das heißt schulen müssen auf
verschiedene szenarien eingestellt seien
entweder auf vollbetrieb das heißt
allerdings andere hygienemaßnahmen oder
eben dann doch wieder auf wechsel
betrieb mit fernunterricht dh gute
digitale ausstattung auf beides glaube
ich sind wir nicht gut vorbereitet und
über den kurz bevorstehenden beginn des
neuen schuljahres mächtigkeit sprechen
mit professor dr gerd schulte körne es
mir nun live zugeschaltet und direktor
der kinder- und jugendpsychiatrie an der
lmu klinik in münchen
guten abend sagen sie uns was sind tipps
die sie den eltern jetzt mit geben
können um ihre kinder auf doch diese
sehr spezielle neue situation
einzustellen wenn sie jetzt bald wieder
zurück in die schule müssen
es gibt verschiedene tipps das erste ist
mal was ich sage nicht so stressig an
diese neue situation heranzugehen denn
man neigt dazu natürlich jetzt alles zu
versuchen damit die kinder gut durch die
schule kommen aber eltern sind halt
keine ersatzlehrer das muss man ganz
klar sei also vermeiden von
überforderungen und reduktion von stress
in den familien sind zwei ganz wichtige
dinge etwas gelassener angehen und auch
eben zu sagen halt wir können nicht
alles kompensieren was jetzt
gesellschaftlich bedingt ist das andere
ist was ich immer wieder sehe ist dass
man auch die sorgen der kinder ernst
nehmen muss gerade wenn kinder besondere
probleme haben im lernen oder weil sie
ängstlich sind oder weil sie zweifel
haben ob sie das wort an geschaffen die
kinder direkt ansprechen mit ihren
sorgen und ihnen dann unterstützung
signalisieren und sagen egal ob die
jetzt das schaffst du denn nicht wir
stehen hinter dir
wir stärken den rücken und gehen mit ihr
durch diese schwierige zeit
andererseits muss man auch sagen es gibt
nicht nur schule man soll auch schöne
dinge miteinander machen vor allem sogar
sollte man das machen damit es auch für
die familie
unterstützend ist also zum beispiel
gemeinsam musizieren oder kochen oder
andere aktivitäten die im nichts mit
schule zu tun haben und entlastend sind
aber was man auch sagen muss es eltern
sollten auch
sich denken sich nicht überfordern und
wichtig ist auch dass die kinder sich
stärken denn ihrem auch ressourcen
deswegen haben wir die seite bewohner
und du gemacht damit sich auch die
jungen leute selbst stärken können über
aktuelle informationen wie kddi ich denn
jetzt in der krise mit meinen belastung
um ganz generell gesprochen wie geht man
mit dieser krise um nicht nur wenn es um
schule geht wie schwierig ist diese
anhaltende pandemie für kinder und
jugendliche hat es vielleicht sogar
langfristige auswirkungen auf ihre
entwicklung das jetzt in so einer zeit
aufwachsen durchaus das trifft
sicherlich alle kinder aber die kinder
gerade die schon vorher ängstlich waren
oder traurig waren oder auch
schwierigkeiten hat mit anderen in
kontakt zu kommen
denen geht es im moment nicht gut und
die ziehen sich noch mehr zurück die
sind noch mehr am handy noch mehr im
internet und vereinsamen und haben sorge
also tatsächlich eine große problematik
auch schon zu kommen wo es die probleme
auch so sind dass sie noch lange nach
der krise andauern werden
deshalb ist hier besondere augenmerk und
vor allem besondere hilfen gefordert
jetzt wird immer wieder darüber
gesprochen dass eine zweite welle kommen
kann das würde auch bedeuten dass
vielleicht schulen doch wieder zu machen
müssten
muss man kinder jetzt besonders darauf
vorbereiten dass sie jetzt zwar erst mal
wieder hin dürfen ihre freunde sehen
können aber es jederzeit wieder dazu
kommen könnte das homeschooling wieder
auf dem tagesplan steht ja das muss man
schon denke ich ist andere ist aber auch
hier wieder in traumatisieren hat weil
letztendlich müsse man jetzt sagen wir
können den normalen schulbetrieb so
nicht erwarten und das dann auch nicht
vorherzusagen sondern wir müssen da hat
das kann sein
und wir sind entspannt und gelassen und
sehen das auf uns zuzukommen das problem
ist eher wann das dass die schule und
auch die lehrkräfte das zu sehen und
auch sagen halt wir haben die
voraussetzung vielleicht jetzt nicht und
wir sehen das auch etwas entspannter
aber was das problem natürlich dabei ist
dass die psyche der kinder da nicht
darunter leidet und dass die eltern
nicht immer überfordert werden vielen
dank herr professor schulte kölner für
die einschätzung zu diesem thema
dankeschön